first thing we do is we go out we look
for the vehicle to vehicle instead you
check the VIN number if it's your
vehicle you turn around back truck up to
it I'll cop to it mark and Larry always
try to put the car on tow before
speaking with the debtor this prevents
the debtor from escaping with the
vehicle we in turn knock on the debtors
door to tell them we're there so they
don't have to worry in the morning that
the car is gone we can get the keys for
the vehicle two people can get the
personal property another vehicle
yeah I'm looking for Wendy Wendy hey
going on I'm with hugs I'm getting
regards in car with the bank we're
taking the clock no you can't do that I
just spoke to them they told me
if you look at the date on here they
have the right to repossess it for 60
days for repo men a big part of the job
is to listen to the variety of excuses
debtors give to prevent repossession
what kind of excuses stuff the list is
endless
I made my payment I sent the payment
what do you mean you take in my car I'm
pregnant
I'm out of work we just moved we lost
our bills you know they know they know
when we get there you know you know damn
well you ain't made your payment my
motto is DTF don't trust anyone
people will lie to you do whatever they
can to not have their vehicle
repossessed although some excuses do
turn out to be true once the
repossession order is given it is
teammates responsibility to recover the
vehicle regardless of what they hear at
the door I don't leave a call with
anybody anybody in this business we've
been in this business a long time your
your black heart you've got no heart
you've got a paycheck sitting there you
want to leave the car you don't get paid